voici donc arrivés sur cette grande
plaine de jeux dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure avec monsieur lavis nous sommes
maintenant compagnie de directeur
adjoint de la base départementale de
loisirs monsieur monnier alors cette
cette plaine de jeu finalement on peut
il faire absolument ce qu'on veut en
effet absolument ce qu'on veut c'est à
dire ça te prennes est utilisé par les
familles qui joue au football font des
parties de boules de pétanque joue au
badminton ou vient de s'y allonger tout
simplement ou utilisent les abords pour
je dirais agrandir un petit peu les
aires de pique nique parce que cette
année notamment avec le beau temps qui a
fait des aires de pique nique sont
prises d'assaut littéralement et les
gens vient de s'installer sur le
pourtour de la base de de la prairie ici
avec vous